I'm coming for you you seek the truth
[Music]
Natha that you wished involve show your
allegiance and all will be revealed that
sounds great
oh wait no I don't part it with false
gods after planet Earth after Earth I've
tracked you know Bo and you think some
paltry mind games and little rock wall
is gonna stop me you've got another
thing coming I'm coming for you and you
can't stop me
for so many years I've traveled across
worlds across the multiverse to do one
thing kill you and now here
you say my life submit and begin your
life anew
show me the knowledge is within you
[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my new crisis on Infinite
Earths video for that opening scene that
they attached to the end of all the
recent midseason finales of the other
shows if you don't remember they did the
exact same thing last year right before
the Elseworlds crossover with the
Elseworlds flash of earth and 90's scene
that they attach to all the end of the
episodes there was a whole bunch of
Easter eggs I'll also cover stuff from
the flash midseason finale and this too
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the crisis on
Infinite Earths videos it starts this
Sunday
that's right Crysis is here we'll do a
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best theory about crisis on the
video how is it going to end well what's
happening here is team flash is watching
a wave of antimatter approaching their
solar system turning the skies red just
like it said in the future newspaper
since season 1 then you had the more
important scene of Nashville's thinking
that he's confronting the monitor Marno
vu that we've been seeing most of this
season interact with the characters we
also saw him during last year's
crossover - there's a couple secrets
that they're trying to slip past you in
this scene some of you I've seen in the
comments have picked up on what they're
doing the person speaking to Nash wells
is the same actor who plays the monitor
but the actor is playing both the
monitor and the anti-monitor during the
crossover at the same time in the same
way that Tom Cavanaugh plays multiple
different characters within seasons of
the flash like he's a reverse flash but
he's also Nash wells two completely
different characters that look kind of
the same
so listen really carefully to this clip
of the monitor speaking to Oliver in the
heroes during the crisis trailer and
then listened to him yelling at Nash
wells in this clip the multiverse
every existence multiplied by
possibility and spread out an infinite
measure now there is a malevolent force
at work one driven by a singular goal
the destruction a polled there is I
don't part it with false gods
most of you probably noticed the
differences in those two voices it
sounds like they're supposed to be
different characters even though it's
the same actor just like Tom Cavanagh
when he's performing reverse-flash
speaks with a very different voice than
when he's speaking his nashville's there
was a deleted scene from one of the
previous crossovers where he actually
does a scene with himself in its reverse
flash going up against earth to harrison
wells and he just goes back and forth
doubling the scene but he does it with
very distinct performances for each
character so that you could tell who is
who now think about what this actor who
normally plays the monitor is saying
when he yells at Nash wells he's
demanding that he bow down to him and
worship him like a God has this version
of the monitor ever said anything
remotely close to that he's asked Oliver
and the rest of them to help him save
the multiverse he's put big tasks on
them but at no point has he ever
referred to himself as a god or demanded
that anyone bow to him and worshiped the
ground that he walks on the person
speaking to Nash wells in this scene has
a completely different personality so
early theory Nash Wells here only thinks
that he's been tracking the monitor
Marno vu this whole time when in fact
he's actually been tracking the
anti-monitor who looks remarkably
similar to the monitor at least right
now they have similar costumes just some
subtle differences in their facial hair
and costume accents but if you weren't
looking closely or listening on good
speakers you wouldn't be able to tell
the difference between these two
characters and I think that's part of
the point of this scene Nash wells is
becoming pariah from comic-book crisis
on Infinite Earths this is what his
costume looks like in all the trailers
after he becomes pariah really what the
anti-monitor is doing or at least he
implies he's doing is revealing the
grand truth of existence the secret of
life or anti life in whatever case in
the multiverse to him that gift is also
meant to be pariahs curse just like
comic book pariah was cursed for his
pursuit of ancient forbidden knowledge
comic book pariah was actually trying to
peer back to the dawn of the universe to
see the Big Bang and that's what alerted
the anti-monitor to the positive matter
universe so that's why he was cursed he
tipped off the event that began crisis
in the comics the seven symbols on the
door here are the symbols representing
the seven different Paragons that the
good version of the
is trying to collect to save the
multiverse it's unclear which symbol
references which Paragon but it's also
unclear how the anti-monitor is
hijacking this place here but the origin
story of the DC TV version of the
anti-monitor will probably be different
than the comic book anti-monitor just
think of this as Nashville's dialing the
cosmic phone to try and get the monitor
in new phone who dis the anti-monitor
winds up picking up Perez comic book
power is that once he is cursed he
becomes immortal and his penance is that
he instantly gets teleported to each
universe in the multiverse right before
it gets wiped by the anti-monitor he's
forced to watch everyone die then he
gets portals to the next epicenter and
so on and so forth across each of the
universes when they get wiped but this
scene is meant to take place right at
the beginning of crisis so talking about
the flash midseason finale there was a
lot of other stuff that happened during
that episode there were a couple big
Easter eggs and references they captured
bloodwork and they put him in the same
device that they put Chester P drunken
to just sort of negate his powers and
keep him contained but he'll come back
at some point later this season they
didn't completely get rid of him they
just put him in the deep freeze the
title of the episode was called The Last
Temptation of Barry Allen a reference to
the Last Temptation of Christ cisco
referenced the babel protocols from
Batman's Tower of Babel storyline in the
Justice League comics his protocols and
plans for how to take out other members
of the Justice League if they ever
turned evil so Cisco back during season
four built one of those into the brand
new version the flash suit at the time
the version that we see in this episode
is just a giant force field around STAR
Labs to prevent Barry when he turns evil
from misusing the particle accelerator
even though they end up using that in
the episode to solve their problem they
name-dropped HR wells from season 3 at
the end of the episode when they're
remembering all the good times with
Barry and all the crazy stuff they've
done the last six seasons they got a
little overly sentimental but they
referenced flashpoint the doppelgangers
from season two was zoom in the earth
two people time-travel being stuck in
the Speed Force and iris having to go
get him it was them basically saying
goodbye to Barry before crisis happened
because they all think that he's going
to die but I know a lot of you were
still asking what's going on with the
velocity X or velocity 10 the fake
godspeed army black hole the ultraviolet
villain and then maybe some other
new villains that'll pop up at the
second half of the season we're still
waiting on reverse-flash to show up
during crisis but he will be part of the
crossover the velocity 10 is probably
connected to what's going on with the
black hole plot that we'll all probably
connect in black hole will be one of the
major villains of the back half of the
season in the comics they're obsessed
with studying the Speed Force and using
it for their own personal gain so that's
what I think that velocity X will have
something to do with that and they'll
have something to do with the fake god
speeds but everyone post your theories
in the comments below remember crisis on
Infinite Earths Episode one is on Sunday
night so of course I'll be doing Easter
Egg videos for all the episodes everyone
click here for that brand new crisis on
Infinite Earths trailer and click here
for that brand new Black Widow trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]
you